what's going on people today we finally
got a long-awaited update for part three
of Attack on Titan the final season
which it turns out is going to be the
longest final season in history because
as you guys know we've already had two
parts which have been spread out over
about three years and now we're finding
out that part three of Attack on Titan
the final season that itself is going to
be split into two parts there's gonna be
part three part one
the first part of part three is gonna
come out on the uh on Friday the 3rd of
March of 2023 so that's when part three
part one will begin and then sometime
later in 2023 we're gonna get the second
half of part three now in terms of why
they're doing this like why they're
splitting it out even further we do
actually have an explanation so mapping
themselves with a studio that make
Attack on Titan they put out a statement
and in that statement they said we
continue to produce with the goal of
broadcasting the complete edition on
March the 3rd however in the process of
proceeding with that production the
amount of work increased significantly
more than expected and it was decided to
be released in the first part and the
second part under the consultation with
each committee company I'm not sure what
that last part means but basically
they're just saying that it was a ton of
work and so they were just like you know
what we had this goal of March 3rd why
don't we just release what we have then
and then finish the rest of it later and
release it in the end of the year that's
basically what they're saying because we
need to remember the end of Attack on
Titan the things that are being drawn
are so complex like that giant skeleton
body moving and marching across the
world that is a lot of work so I totally
understand why they would um why they
had to push back you know releasing the
full season I I get that it's just so
funny that the final season is gonna
technically have like
four or five parts you know we had part
one part two the beginning of part three
and then later in the year we'll get
part four basically like there's one
season split into four parts
um but anyway now that we've explained
all that it's time to move on to the
trailer itself because there were a few
interesting things in this trailer that
are probably worth talking about so in
the beginning of the trailer it opens up
with Aaron waking up under the tree like
it basically the exact same way he did
in the first episode
um but what I'm interested in here is I
think they're about to wreck on
something because if you guys remember
in episode one when Aaron wakes up from
under the tree he has this nightmare and
he sees a bunch of different visions and
those were anime original Creations you
know those Visions were not in the manga
in the manga he saw a vision of Mikasa
saying see you later to him and then
that actually became an important plot
Point later in the manga I'm not going
to spoil what that plot point is but
Newman greeters know that Mikasa being
in his dream in the beginning of the
manga does have some significance
towards the end now the fact is the
anime never showed us this so I think
what they're going to do potentially is
you know they've clearly reanimated the
opening scene of episode one so what
they might potentially do is show us
Mikasa saying see you later in his dream
in the anime as well so that when it
becomes relevant later on you know at
least they've put it out there in the
world so moving on from Aaron waking up
we then get a bunch of awesome clips of
people getting crushed by the rumbling
it looks really well animated it looks
fantastic and one thing I wanted to
highlight about this moment was that we
see the statue of helos if you guys
remember uh in part one of the final
season Willie Tiber and mcgath they were
chilling in the headquarters for the
military and that statue of helos was
right there in front of them and I think
Willie was talking about how like he
came here just to see it and blah blah
blah and so in this moment we see Marley
is destroyed Liberia was getting crushed
and yeah the statue of fellows is no
more and I think the significance of
this I mean number one
um hellos was the guy who allegedly
defeated the founding Titan and so the
significance of hell is the statue now
being destroyed and everything else
being destroyed around it it's basically
meant to be ironic because like this is
the man who allegedly stopped the
founder and now the founder Aaron is
basically biting back destroying
everything outside the walls and there's
nothing anyone can do to stop him really
the trailer then basically comes to an
end with Aaron's giant skeleton body
just kind of uh moving forward and uh
yeah we see it from behind it looks
really really good and then it
transitions to Aaron as a kid this is
one of the most iconic moments of the
entire manga that's coming to life here
um it's Aaron basically you know
achieving that goal of Freedom he gets
to go out to the outside world no one is
stopping him he can see whatever he
wants to see he can go wherever he wants
to go and he can kill whoever he wants
to kill
um and so yeah that is the trailer for
part three part one of the final season
also the day of the week this comes out
is a Friday which is a lot different
from usual normally these episodes will
come out on a Sunday UK time and then
Japanese this time I'm pretty sure it
was Monday when the episodes normally
came out but yeah and now they're coming
out on Fridays apparently which is an
interesting change not sure why they've
made that but I don't really mind but
just something worth pointing out and
yeah that's basically everything I have
to say about this trailer
um but I would say that if you're a fan
of this channel like if you're not new
to this channel then on a completely
separate note I'm working on part seven
of my ultimate timeline of what if
Irving got the Colossal Titan and yeah
it's coming along pretty well I've
planned out the video and like bullet
points so far and we have a ton of art
commission for it
um which you know not all of it's been
finished it's still a long way to go but
that'll be coming out sometime in
February between mid to late February
I'm really proud of how this Series has
gone so fast got over 2 million views in
total um all the different parts put
together so really amazing stuff and the
ending will be pretty good I am looking
forward to seeing you guys reactions to
it just like all the other parts in this
series there will be major deaths
because one thing I wanted to do with
this series is just like you know I
wanted to capture the essence of like
season one of Attack on Titan when
anyone literally anyone could die it
felt like and we're going to continue
that so people will die there will be
some sharks there will be twists and
turns
um and yeah it's gonna look amazing it's
gonna look amazing there's lots of
different stuff there's been
commissioned for this one so yeah as
always thank you guys for watching and
be sure to hit that subscribe button if
you haven't already and until the next
one peace out